you have to see the world through the
character's eyes
you can't be judgmental you can't like
or dislike you have to see the world
through them
to talk a little bit more about the
going from phoebe
in series one i mean i know she didn't
write it exclusively but you know
largely it was phoebe's words to
to moving through to different writers
how much
do you think about the character kind of
progressing and how much can you
you know how much does she still feel
like the original character that phoebe
wrote
well i mean it's a multitude of things
really i think what i really enjoy
now is is finding a confidence when it
within myself of going
i feel as though i know her more than
anyone now because i've played her for
so long
uh so to find that confidence within
yourself is actually a lot of fun
um and you're right you know with having
new writers it changes the energy it
changes the dynamic and
um it makes it a really
you know it's a real collaboration and
it's all about conversation i think what
i've learned is going for
through each season is that being honest
about
what you loved and maybe what didn't
feel is natural or what didn't feel
right and
um you know i feel very lucky to be able
to have these conversations and
and you know sid general and the
production team are always wanting my
opinions and my feelings
and so you feel really valued in that um
space you know
saran is that the same for you i mean
you know sally is such a
particular writer she's got such a style
we know her so well
did you feel at all confident or how
confident did you feel about kind of
putting your own mark onto her words
well um at the initial meeting sally
just before we were about to read she
said i don't know who's going to play
this
because they need to be this this this
this and this and this and this and this
and i don't know who's going to do it
would you like to read that thing i was
like okay
i mean the pressure was um was quite
something but i think
and she'd seen a lot of people but i
think what sally and me
had was just this love for and lister
and and um this deep passion of wanting
to dive into every aspect of her and try
and get as much as we possibly could
so we kind of we fell in love with each
other we fell in love with analysta
she she took me to shibjin and we walked
and we talked and
we stomped around the ground and then
sally started to write with me
in mind and we worked so closely on
all the diaries until it became apparent
that we couldn't ever get through all
that
stuff and we had to concentrate on what
we were doing in season one
um and then we were sat in her kitchen
um going through some stuff and she said
i want you to exec next year because i i
i feel like we're in this together and
so they invited me to do that this year
which
is amazing so we we work really closely
and being on the production team from
the beginning this year
has just been amazing and like joe said
you know
you feel very privileged when when
because when you're a young baby actor
you don't you don't get that privilege
you know you don't get
asked or you do and then they say oh
great and then
you you don't quite feel like you've
been listened to so it
it's it's amazing to be part of
something
because you're carrying it as well so
it's really important that
you're happy on set or as happy as you
can be with all the other decisions
that are going on and um so yeah i do i
feel like
i'm really part of that team i'm
moving forward now um but it's
yeah it's it's certainly a privilege and
i know that
glenda do you still feel that i mean you
you presumably
you know the others were more or less
sort of on equal puttings with
the collaborators that they worked with
but you have
years of amazing experience and
your writer and your director while
there are established figures in the
industry
are sort of you know running in your
wake how much did you feel
but how much did you feel able to or how
much do you
put your own stamp onto their words how
fixed were that was andrea's script
well but let me go
to my basic rule um
you have to see the world through the
character's eyes
you can't be judgmental you can't like
or dislike you have to see the world
through them
and the other rule is that everyone is
responsible for that old show
however large however small be the play
be the film be it
tv so the things that
my two preceding actresses have been
speaking off
which is that community that sense of
community that closeness
that working together is is vitally
important
and that was something that we have in
spades where we did elizabeth is missing
we had a marvelous cast a marvelous crew
um it was really amazing
to do it there were days when i thought
i'd contracted if not one at least both
of the diseases but that's far and
parcel of the work we do
you know you started to talk before
about the relationship of dementia and
you know that's why you were kind of
interested sort of what did you
do in the way of research or kind of how
much do you let the writer get on and do
that research and how much do you
get involved in in the kind of backstory
of your character
well obviously the the book itself
elizabeth is missing is the report of
as i've said her granddaughter's seeing
her grandmother go through this and also
the producers on the film introduced
um me to doctors who actually work well
certainly one doctor who works in this
field i believe she's chair of the
dementia society
and one of the things that i found most
curious in reading
the script was a woman who had been
you know the kind of ideal um
wife mother never caused any trouble
never had any rouse
in the throes of the illness becomes
upon occasions absolutely furious and i
said to the doctor
where does that come from where does
that
you know corrupted energy in a way come
from and she said something which i
found immensely helpful
she said it's frustration and that i
could understand you know what i mean i
could
we all feel frustrated but in that sense
where you're feeling something which
the individual is but they don't know
what it is or where it's come from
that was an added
light to be able to see through what is
going on but it is something that as
i've said
you know we are living longer um not
only in this country but all western it
seems to me
democratic societies are and these
illnesses are
there they're present and we as a
society have to accept that this
is not just on the basic level of being
nice or kind or caring for people
this is something that we as a society
are going to have to deal with
and um it is one of the terrible
pluses if there can be a plus about the
kobe crisis we're in at the moment
is that the whole issue of social care
is going up the political ladder
and it's we hope that there can be an
approach to these particular illnesses
which do not become party political they
are national
they affect us all in one way or another
and so we you know we have to bite the
bullet
rather unfortunate choice of phrase but
knowledge that this is waiting out there
and we as a society have to
gather ourselves together and do
something about it something positive
about
it those moments blender were just like
so um because my mom had alzheimer's and
i worked with the alzheimer's society
and
you know those anger that the anger that
frustration
and the bravery you had to really go for
those moments
because they're shocking and in you know
they're shocking in a drama but in real
life they're
really heartbreaking and really shocking
and it's about
people understanding people with
dementia
people who live with dementia and i
think i think it was really important
that
those moments went in because it's
because people don't understand they
they're scared of people who show
themselves like that and if they don't
know anything about the disease
then you know they're pushed to one side
so i just thought
yeah i thought it was wonderful that
that side
came out i very much hone in on what you
said about people not understanding
i mean because those words have been in
our society for some time
so people know it's there but i was
amazed when the film came out
and i'd been going down the local tescos
or whatever and people
would come up to me and say that you
know they had that direct
experience but it is something that
we know it's there but we have
i think as well obviously i'm going to
blame
politicians for this but we have as a
society and i think as
all political parties walked around this
great big black hole that's out there
waiting for us
and that is why hopefully now we will
begin to realize
that we have to do something and the
something that we have to do
can be positive it can engage us all
it's more than just finding another
vaccine do you know what i mean it's
it's not down that area it's how do we
actually
care for ourselves because that's what
we're talking about here
because our lifespan is extending and
we do have things as as human beings
that we can't share with each other that
we can recognize
we've seen during this kogit pandemic
you know people doing the most
extraordinary things to help each other
we just have to be very careful that it
doesn't get pushed into some kind of box
that says oh well you know that's the
nhs and social care or whatever but it's
gonna
do with us it does have something to do
with all of us
[Music]
you